bonsoir à toutes et à tous si vous nous
rejoignez à l'instant sur les chaînes
parlementaires LCP et Public Sénat 2h50
c'était la durée donc de ce débat
d'entre deux tours entre Emmanuel Macron
et Marine Le Pen convient de suivre
évidemment en direct sur nos antennes on
va être ensemble pendant 40 minutes
jusqu'à minuit 30 pour à chaud analyser
ce débat les phrases les plus saillantes
les moments forts et puis peut-être
aussi l'impact de cette soirée sur le
vote de dimanche effectivement Thomas
les deux finalistes se sont affrontés ce
soir les deux finalistes du second tour
d'élection présidentielle qui aura lieu
dimanche prochain alors à quatre jours
et bien de cette élection très
importante en France on verra s'il y a
un gagnant ou un perdant ce soir on va
décrypter tout ça évidemment avec nos
invités mais je vous propose de partir
tout de suite à la pleine Saint-Denis où
se trouve alexandre Poussin Alexandre
vous avez suivi ce débat depuis la
plaine Saint-Denis où a lieu et bien
c'est le débat d'entre-deux-tours ce
soir il y avait deux tons il y avait
deux stratégies différentes dans ce
débat
Brigitte en deux stratégies différentes
avec un Emmanuel Macron être très
offensif très piquant face à son
adversaire en fait il n'a eu de cesse et
bien de vouloir montrer les incohérences
de son programme Emmanuel Macron à
chaque fois qu'il parlait de ses mesures
il parlait aussi des propositions de son
adversaire pour démontrer qu'elles
étaient
inefficaces et puis bien sûr il y a eu
un moment fort dans ce débat d'entre eux
la séquence sur la guerre en Ukraine sur
la Russie ou le président candidat et
bien a voulu orienter le débat sur le
prêt contacté par le Front national
auprès d'une banque russe proche du
pouvoir du Kremlin c'était en 2015 et
cette phrase forte d'Emmanuel Macron
quand vous parlez à la Russie Marine Le
Pen vous parlez à votre banquier donc
voilà un Emmanuel Macron très offensif
qui a voulu montrer qu'il y avait deux
visions de la France qui s'opposait ce
soir et puis de l'autre côté une Marine
Le Pen est bien plus calme plus sereine
complètement différente du débat de 2017
et Marine Le Pen qui a joué la carte du
social
finalement assez montré dans la
continuité de sa stratégie de campagne
vraiment sur les questions sociales elle
a beaucoup parlé d'inégalités de
l'écologie punitive des taxes sur les
carburants elle a parlé pouvoir d'achat
elle a parlé santé avec quelques parties
plus droitières forcément sur
l'immigration et sur l'interdiction du
voile dans l'espace public mais elle n'a
pas voulu s'apesantir trop longtemps sur
ces sujets donc voilà deux visions de la
France deux style qui se sont opposés ce
soir et on ne peut pas dire qu'il y a un
grand perdant ce soir dans ce débat
merci Alexandre bah c'est une question
qu'on va poser à nos invités j'accueille
Michel cotta bonsoir heureux de vous
retrouver sur ce plateau journaliste
politique chroniqueuse au point et puis
il faudrait résumer on peut pas résumer
tout ce que vous avez fait donc je fais
simple Céline brag bonsoir Céline vous
êtes directrice générale de doc ça
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
spécialiste en communication politique
et Pascal Perino ou non plus on ne vous
présente plus c'est quand même vous êtes
politologue professeur émérite des
universités à Sciences Po et ancien
directeur du CVP alors je rebondis sur
ce que disait Alexandre poussat pour
vous il y a pas de gagnant il y a pas de
perdant ce soir en effet c'est un débat
vous savez c'était le huitième sous la
5e République de ce genre et d'habitude
on disait toujours il y a pas
véritablement de vainqueur c'est un
débat équilibré ça n'a pas été le cas la
dernière fois en 2017 il y avait un
vainqueur c'était Emmanuel Macron il y
avait quelqu'un qui avait perdu
énormément de points 4 à 5 points à peu
près dans ce débat c'était Marine Le Pen
cette fois-ci on redoue avec la
tradition on a un bilan beaucoup plus
équilibré même si les styles de chacun
des protagonistes ce soir était
extrêmement
extrêmement différent on avait un
président candidat qui maîtrisait en
effet ces dossiers comme il nous a
habitués qui présentait de manière
parfois un peu idyllique son bilan parce
que il savait en effet qu'il allait se
faire pilonner un peu sur ce bilan et
qu'il n'avait plus la fraîcheur la
nouveauté de 2017
c'était également un Emmanuel Macron et
là c'est un peu à rebours par rapport à
2017 qui a manié parfois le registre de
la polémique il a traité son adversaire
de Majax vous dites n'importe quoi il
accusait de provoquer éventuellement une
guerre civile enfin bon parfois il ne
faisait pas dans la nuance alors que de
manière assez surprenante on avait une
Marine Le Pen comme elle l'est depuis sa
campagne de premier tour ketesse avec un
registre où le langage était
incroyablement contrôlée elle a très peu
polémiquer avec Emmanuel Macron elle
adressait bien sûr avis un bilan qui
était pas du tout idyllique extrêmement
sombre du quinquennat là il n'y avait
aucune surprise et puis elle a eu un
style qui était presque plus politique
que Macron plus concret elle se mettait
sans arrêt du côté des citoyens de la
manière sur le pouvoir d'achat c'était
caricatural on avait un Emmanuel Macron
qui parlait bit qui parlait Insee etc et
puis on avait une candidate du
rassemblement national qui elle dans la
lignée de sa campagne de très pouvoir
d'achat Michel cotta et est-ce que c'est
pas le stade ultime d'une forme de
banalisation de l'extrême droite voulue
par Marine Le Pen depuis plusieurs
années ce second débat ce match retour
entre Emmanuel Macron et Marine Le Pen
et finalement son attitude à elle oui
bon on peut pas dire qu'effectivement
elle est reproduit les mêmes erreurs
euh qui a 5 ans mais on peut pas dire
non plus Emmanuel Macron et et reproduit
son style moi je suis pas tellement
d'accord avec
votre journaliste qui dit on a été très
très
belliqueux je pense qu'au contraire il a
lutté contre son arrogance parce que
c'était ça
le risque on avait ça fait 15 jours
qu'on dit le risque c'est son on lui a
pas tiré un sourire ironique alors qu'il
y a eu beaucoup de souris ironique quand
même d'avoir une Le Pen donc je trouve
quand même que de ce point de vue
personne n'a perdu personne n'a gagné
mais chacun s'est équilibré mais après
sur le débat moi je trouve que c'est un
débat très clair et j'ai trouvé ça
plutôt intéressant de bout en bout d'un
débat où on choisit son camp
effectivement on le choisit avec un
certain nombre d'arguments c'est vrai
que Marine Le Pen a été plus humaine
toutes les fois qu'il y a calmé
sur l'humain elle est effectivement mais
autrement moi je trouve que c'est un
débat intéressant de bout en bout parce
que sur tous les points importants oui
il y a des choix chacun les a assumés et
c'est un bon vous avez un bon début vous
avez en partie répond à mes questions
mais je la repose de la même façon c'est
une braque est-ce que on est dans la
boutissement d'une forme de banalisation
du de l'extrême droite voulu par Marine
Le Pen oui c'était dans la forme du
débat faisait partie d'ailleurs d'un de
ces enjeux il y en avait plusieurs et en
réalité je dirais que c'est c'est
surtout elle qui devait gagner ce débat
mais je pense que ils se sont
neutralisés en réalité et sur la
dédiabolisation de Marine Le Pen en
revanche là-dessus je pense qu'elle a
bien réussi son pari un moment quand je
regardais ce débat je me disais si
quelqu'un était étranger il connaissait
pas du tout la vie politique il aurait
pu imaginer quelle était la présidente
sortant et qu'elle avait face à elle un
jeune loup qui l'attaquait qu'il attaqué
parce que la première partie c'était
quand même très étonnant c'est à dire je
trouvais que vraiment Emmanuel Macron
montait au front systématiquement et
elle elle a su contrairement au dernier
débat garder son calme maintenant
elle devait être particulièrement
convaincante sur ces sujets de
prédilection ce sur lesquels d'ailleurs
les Français la créditent finalement
plus que qu'Emmanuel Macron à savoir le
pouvoir d'achat et les retraites et j'ai
trouvé quand on était en tout cas dans
le thème pouvoir d'achat
je trouvais pas si bonne que ça elle a
été mise un peu en difficulté sur
l'histoire des salaires par Emmanuel
Macron sur la partie retraite elle a
déroulé sur un propos un peu technique
et après elle s'est employée à
disqualifier le bilan économique mais on
est on est sorti du sujet retraite alors
que je pense qu'elle avait des arguments
très très forts pour dire de manière
très claire à toutes les personnes qui
ont travaillé par exemple à 20 ans qui
le paraissait absolument insupportable
de travailler 45 ans et que elle elle
voulait pas ça etc et là je trouve
qu'elle a loupé une de pouvoir vraiment
s'affirmer sur ces sujets Emily
s'appelle ce qui en a eu un débat qui
était assez technique quand même avec
projet contre projet est-ce que ça ça
peut séduire de nouveaux électeurs
est-ce que ça peut déplacer des voix
mais en tout cas c'est vrai que c'était
deux visions très différentes et surtout
les sujets ils avaient vraiment une
opposition très forte donc ça c'était
très clair avec c'est vrai deux
approches complètement différentes un
Macron plutôt moi je l'ai trouvé aussi
sur la défensive en tout cas sur la
première partie du débat peut-être après
il a retrouvé un petit peu l'élan quand
il est plus libre et qu'il est pas en
écoute surjoué parce qu'on l'a quand
même vu en écoutant un petit peu sur
jouer au début dans les premières
minutes dans les premières minutes
de coupe était surveillés c'était un
petit peu surjoué quand même avec un peu
une espèce de compassion dans le regard
que c'est un peu particulier
je suis très à l'écoute je vous laisse
parler je souris gentiment je suis très
malade après il s'en est libéré et c'est
là que je pense où il est devenu
meilleur parce que il était dans ce
candidat qu'on ne le connaissait en 2017
beaucoup plus avec son projet à défendre
concrètement il était beaucoup plus
authentique et il avait son projet elle
elle a joué en effet sur le ressenti
elle a joué sur le quotidien des
Français elle a joué sur des choses très
concrètes à chaque fois qu'elle a piqué
elle était très concrète 400000 pauvres
en plus chez vous les entrées
industriels alors que lui partait dans
des explications très technocrate qu'on
n'écoutait pas forcément jusqu'au bout
c'est vrai que ça c'est un procès qu'on
lui avait fait en 2017
quand même pour le Mozart de la finance
vous avez un très mauvais bilan
économique vous êtes il lui dit vous
êtes climato-sceptique à lui répond vous
êtes climato hypocrite il y avait quand
même du travail derrière mais pour
répondre à votre question parce que je
voudrais y répondre sur l'extrême droite
je pense que c'est pas elle qui n'a pas
réussi qui a réussi sa dédiabolisation
c'est lui qui n'a pas réussi à la
rediaboliser et à la fin sont finish
c'est de dire le 24 avril c'est un vote
clair c'est un référendum pour ou contre
l'Union européenne pour ou contre une
vision de la civilisation il y est pas
arrivé pendant la discussion on a eu
très peu de sujets sur l'extrême droite
à part le voile et un tout petit peu
l'immigration et encore elle s'en est
plutôt pas mal sortie
son image je pense que l'extrême droite
elle y était pas vous avez raison c'est
un mot là-dessus ensuite on regarde la
première expérience parce que si vous
voulez je partage tout à fait ce
diagnostic l'extrême droite l'extrême
droite huit dix jours là on a entendu
parler que de cela le Front républicain
la lutte contre l'extrême droite la
mobilisation et ça n'a pas marché ce
n'était pas là ça n'a pas marché donc
quelque part ça n'a pas marché le
président ça n'a pas marché regardez sur
les mobilisations ça fait un flop et le
thème même de l'extrême droite en tant
que tel ne marche plus on n'avait pas
une candidate d'extrême droite ce soir
face à Marine Le Pen non on n'avait pas
on a une candidate nationale populiste
c'est pas l'extrême droite autant sinon
sinon les mots non plus de sens Éric
Zemmour est un vrai candidat d'extrême
droite représentant l'héritage d'une
d'une extrême droite moracienne on voit
bien que Marine Le Pen c'est tout à fait
autre chose et on le voit
particulièrement sur le terrain
économique et social comment voulez-vous
la qualifier d'extrême droite sur ce
terrain là elle ne développe absolument
pas des positions
ultra libérales qui déborderaient la
droite
on a la priorité nationale qu'elle
défend la priorité nationale vous savez
la priorité nationale d'abord elle
existe en France quand vous regardez le
monde de la fonction publique et dont
vous franchissez la frontière pour aller
en Suisse et ensuite vous avez même la
préférence cantonale donc
je ne crois pas que et vous savez en
1932 il y avait une loi qui était une
loi votée par un gouvernement de centre
gauche qui était une loi en effet qui
ferait bon la priorité nationale donc il
faut un peu si vous voulez dédramatiser
ce thème et se rendre compte que dans
les couches populaires ça rencontre un
écho alors on va regarder ensemble la
première extrait de de ce débat c'est
cette échange autour de la Russie les
amitiés russes de Marine Le Pen et
surtout ce prêt russe pas encore
totalement remboursé on écoute vous
dépendez du pouvoir russe et que vous
dépendez de Monsieur Poutine parce que
quelques mois après avoir dit cela
Madame Le Pen vous avez contracté un
prêt en 2015 auprès d'une banque russe
la First check Russian Bank proche du
pouvoir en septembre 2014 puis vous avez
ensuite reboutiqué ce prêt auprès
d'autres acteurs tout ça est totalement
transparent connu notifié notarié
qui sont impliqués d'ailleurs ensuite
dans la guerre en Syrie et donc vous ne
parlez pas à d'autres dirigeants vous
parlez à votre banquier quand vous
parlez de la Russie c'est ça le problème
Madame Le Pen alors peut-être que c'est
aussi ce qui ce qui fait que on le voit
bien dès qu'il y a des positions
courageuses et difficiles à prendre
ni vous niveau représentants de sons
et ça n'est pas hasard si il y a 5 ans
la Russie était intervenue dans la
campagne ce qui a été prouvé pour me
déstabilisé et si vous avez toujours été
ambigu sur le sujet parce que vous
n'êtes pas dans une situation de
puissance à puissance que vous ne pouvez
pas défendre correctement sur ce sujet
des intérêts de la France parce que vos
intérêts sont liés à des gens proches du
pouvoir russe Emmanuel Macron parce que
il a accès à l'intégralité des
informations des services
français et public cette pertinemment
que ce qu'il dit est faux il s'est
pertinemment que je suis une femme
absolument et totalement libre et que je
défends parce que je suis une patriote
que je l'ai démontré toute ma vie la
France et les Français toujours en toute
circonstances maintenant ce que vous
dites faut plusieurs fois d'abord je
vous ai retrouvé un tweet que j'avais
fait le 9 novembre 2014 je soutiens une
Ukraine libre qui ne soit soumise ni aux
États-Unis ni à l'Union européenne ni à
la Russie voilà ma position c'est la
même c'était la même en Irak en 2003
c'est la même pour l'Ukraine aujourd'hui
je considère
non mais pardon d'accord nous allons y
venir monsieur Macron nous allons y
venir la Crimée n'a pas dû vous poser
énormément de problèmes non plus puisque
vous avez reçu Monsieur Poutine en
grande pompe à Versailles vous avez reçu
en 2017 vous avez reçu Monsieur Poutine
à Brégançon sur votre lieu de vacances
et vous avez d'ailleurs tenu à cette
occasion exactement les propos que je
tiens vous avez dit à cette occasion que
la Russie devait être réarrimé à
l'Europe vous avez dit qu'il fallait
faire l'Europe de Lisbonne à Vladivostok
donc ce que vous faites aujourd'hui
c'est peut-être dans une posture
Cottin on savait que ce serait un des
angles d'attaque d'Emmanuel Macron
contre Marine Le Pen est-ce que ça peut
porter cette attaque est-ce que ça
l'affaiblit deux choses peut-être
contradictoires la première c'est que je
trouve que dans la campagne Marine Le
Pen c'était assez bien dépatouiller de
cette histoire russe tandis que
évidemment
Eric Zemmour est plongé la tête dedans
et au fond l'erreur d'Éric Zemmour a
quelques bars rendus moins
très sensible latitude de Marine Le Pen
moyen dans quoi on sait tous
qu'effectivement avec les Russes il y a
un certain nombre de d'accord implicite
avec la Hongrie que quelque part les
pays de l'Est européen ont
agrège beaucoup l'intérêt des pays
d'extrême droite bon tout ça on le sait
elle s'en est très bien dépatouiller je
trouve que ce soir
pas tellement voilà ce soir elle a quand
même été l'objet d'une critique que
toutes les Français peuvent comprendre
et qui a été assez net alors voilà
est-ce que
le bénéfice en revient à celui qui a
fait la polémique et qui a lancé la
polémique avec ce temps-là ou à celle
qui a répondu plutôt bien en tout cas
elle peut dire merci sur cette histoire
ruse à Éric vous parlez à votre banquier
quand vous parlez à la Russie et mise à
Bastille c'est l'une des phrases qui
restera de ce débat oui oui c'est assez
fort elle avait essayé d'anticiper le
problème avec une conférence de presse
qui était sur la politique étrangère et
qui a pas bien fonctionné parce qu'elle
n'était pas très crédible et qu'on se
sentait qu'elle essayait de se
dépatouiller comme vous le dites c'était
pas très bien réussi pendant la campagne
de l'antre de Tours et là en effet là il
a touché je pense qu'il l'a touché
profondément qu'avec cette punchline
c'était quand même assez fort et qu'elle
a eu du mal à s'en départir en sortant
bon ce tweet c'était pas c'était pas
très bien vu après je pense qu'elle a
essayé de remettre les choses au clair
et c'est vrai que la situation est
compliquée parce que Emmanuel Macron
c'est quand même mis en scène beaucoup
avec ses échanges avec Poutine au début
au début de la crise ukrainienne un peu
moins par la suite et ça n'a pas donné
tellement d'effet il a gardé le dialogue
mais il a jamais réussi donc elle a
essayé un petit peu de lui voilà de lui
renvoyer ça avec ses rencontres bon moi
je dirais aussi un peu match nul elle a
pas été très bonne à se défendre mais
bon il a sa pas non plus je pense
tellement déco forcément parce que la
crise elle continue on voit bien que
s'en sort pas donc bon je suis pas sûr
que ça aide c'est vrai qu'on voyait
cette attaque contre l'alliance en fait
entre la Russie et
Marine Le Pen finalement est-ce que la
bonne attaque c'était de l'attaquer sur
le banquier russe
écoutez ça faisait partie des arguments
polémiques qui sont utilisés tout de
même depuis de nombreuses années à
l'égard de Marine Le Pen Marine Le Pen a
répondu en effet que les banques
françaises
ne lui avait pas offert de financement
et que donc elle avait été voir chez les
Russes elle aurait peut-être pu aller
voir ailleurs
étant donné tout de même la sensibilité
du terrain russe dès l'époque où elle
contracte ce prêt alors je crois que moi
ça touche beaucoup plus le camp
d'Emmanuel Macron mais c'est important
dans un débat de rassemblée
parce que pour la base sociale populaire
de Marine Le Pen je crois que c'est un
argument qui ne touche absolument pas
c'est cette dimension internationale
n'est pas présente dans la le cœur de
l'électorat qui se retrouvera dimanche
derrière Marine Le Pen alors justement
c'est une marque cette dimension
internationale c'est vraiment
effectivement j'avais une priorité des
Français maintenant ça fait partie de la
stature présidentielle et c'est ce sur
quoi Marine Le Pen est en et un déficit
par rapport à Emmanuel Macron
sur quel thématique que vous faites plus
confiance à Marine Le Pen ou Emmanuel
Macron il arrive très largement en tête
sur les questions internationales on est
sur du 64 versus 33 pour elle donc de
gens qui lui font plus confiance
effectivement dans notre dernier sur le
pouvoir d'achat alors que sur le pouvoir
d'achat c'est le cas et le peut-être
quand même ce qui pouvait manquer
c'était le la suite du raisonnement
c'est-à-dire qu'on a bien cette attaque
sur le banquierrus maintenant ça
signifierait que derrière le risque
serait un renversement des alliances et
on n'est pas allé jusque là et pour
quelqu'un qui suit le débat et qui en
effet ne serait pas un soutien de Macron
il pourrait se dire bon ok d'accord et
et quoi enfin et quoi c'est pas quel est
le problème en fait quelque part c'est
pas si grave donc je pense pas que en
effet ça a été un message qui est pu
convaincre des indécis alors on va à
présent retrouver Laurent jacobelli qui
est porte-parole de Marine Le Pen et qui
était à l'instant au micro d'Alexandre
pusard
je crois de haut tenue avec des échanges
et puis un Emmanuel Macron tel qu'on est
hautain donneur de leçons désinvolte
dans sa position comme si les Français
ne regardaient pas se débat comme s'il
était chez lui et une Marine Le Pen qui
allait dans le fond des sujets qui
expliquait son programme elle est calme
sérénité je pense que ce soir les
Français ont vu le vrai visage des deux
candidats et je crois très sincèrement
que c'est une bonne nouvelle on l'a vu
Emmanuel Macron il a essayé de pointer
les incohérences dans le programme de
Marine Le Pen il a essayé il n'y ait pas
parvenu il s'est je crois pourvoyé quand
on a parlé des 600 milliards de dettes
il a nié que c'est pour le plus des deux
tiers extérieurs au phénomène covid tout
le monde a vérifié et tout le monde a vu
qu'il avait menti voilà Emmanuel Macron
qui a été sur de lui-même dans la
posture et dans le verbe mais qui dans
le fond a menti mais ça fait cinq ans
qu'il nous fait le coup et depuis 5 ans
on a vu une Marine Le Pen a complètement
transformé dans ce débat beaucoup plus
dans le contrôle dans le calme c'est
c'est un point positif pour vous on vous
l'avez dit depuis 5 ans Marine Le Pen a
elle est dans cette campagne elle-même
vraiment et je crois que ce soir ça
s'est vu je crois qu'elle a parlé avec
émotion avec sincérité avec précision et
que les Français se soient ont vu
qu'elles pouvaient être présidente de la
République est-ce qu'au final les deux
candidats se sont neutralisés dans ce
débat non je ne le crois pas je crois
que dans le fond et dans la forme il y a
un vainqueur c'est Marine Le Pen
clairement Emmanuel Macron a ses
réfugiés dans l'auto-satisfaction
classique incapable de se remettre en
cause même sur ces échecs et je le
répète une fois encore cette
désinvolture dans l'attitude qui montre
bien ça désinvolture aussi pour gérer
les affaires de l'État alors on continue
de de dérouler et de de s'attacher
peut-être au moment fort de ces deux
heures 50 de débat avec un autre extrait
que je vous propose quand vous propose
tout de suite qui qui porte autour du
voile avec notamment cette phrase forte
d'Emmanuel Macron vous allez créer la
guerre civile dans les cités
je suis pour l'interdiction du voile
dans l'espace public je l'ai dit je l'ai
dit de la manière la plus claire je
pense que le voile est
un uniforme imposé par les islamistes je
pense que les grandes parties des jeunes
femmes qui le mettent ne peuvent pas
faire autrement en réalité même si elles
n'osent pas le dire cette situation
n'est pas admissible dans notre pays
donc il faut
libérer l'ensemble de ces femmes il faut
faire reculer les islamistes et pour
cela je le crois il faut interdire le
voile dans l'espace public moi je suis
pour la loi de 1905 c'est notre
République la République et laïque la
laïcité ça n'est pas à combattre une
religion et donc avec moi il n'y aura
pas l'interdiction ni du foulard ni de
la kippa ni de quelques signes religieux
dans l'espace public parce que le
principe d'égalité fait que si vous
rentrez dans cette logique Madame Le Pen
vous interdirez tous les signaux
religieux dans l'espace public et pas
simplement le foulard
non mais j'ai lu la Constitution
française vous m'excuserez de cela et et
elle est
les lois que vous prendrez
même si vous étiez élu ce que je ne
souhaite pas évidemment elles devront
respecter une constitution bon dans les
services publics il y a une neutralité
des services publics à l'état absolue
par contre dans la cité
vous allez créer la guerre civile si
vous faites ça je vous le dis en toute
sincérité
vous allez éclairer la guerre civile
Emmanuel Macron il y a des propos forts
qui viennent d'être prononcer là il y a
deux de visions deux interprétations
finalement de la laïcité c'est en ça
quand même on a beau dire qu'il y a une
déabolisation de Marine Le Pen ouais
c'est sur ce terrain là que quand même
j'ai trouvé qu'une diabolisation
existait effectivement il y a ce cette
compréhension de d'un islam qui est
forcément islamiste du côté de Marine Le
Pen et de l'autre côté de côté
d'Emmanuel Macron les religions sont
toutes égalité sauf quand elles ne
respectent pas la République donc je
trouve que là il y a un vrai vrai débat
entre eux et moi j'ai trouvé ça très
intéressant ça ne m'a pas étonné mais je
trouve que c'est quand même la partie
dans lequel Marine Le Pen a été si j'ose
dire la plus Marine Le Pen
c'était attendu
là où je peux me le permettre et c'est
dévoiler en effet plutôt d'extrême
droite mais je suis enfin Emmanuel
Macron a beaucoup évolué aussi sur le
sujet quand même parce que on avait
quand même des ministres et notamment
Jean-Michel Blanquer qui disait il y a
quelques mois encore que le voile
n'était pas forcément souhaitable dans
la société française on avait un
Darmanin qui était quand même aussi
plutôt en soutien et sur la campagne
et c'est vrai qu'Emmanuel Macron a
toujours eu à peu près cette posture
c'est-à-dire le en même temps on
resterait éloigné 1905 on interdit rien
mais c'était le seul quelque part qui
tenait ça et c'était le seul à mettre du
temps je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
on a eu beaucoup de temps avant son
discours sur la laïcité parce que
justement il avait du mal à trancher
dans sa majorité entre les défendeurs de
voile partout et puis ceux qui
trouvaient que c'était pas souhaitable
dans la société par contre là c'est vrai
qu'il lui a fait accoucher de se voile
interdit alors que pendant la semaine de
l'entre-deux tours elle avait nuancé son
propos après avoir rencontré une
grand-mère qui portait le voile très
souriante et qui lui a dit quand même
vous allez pas me faire ça moi c'est
culturel moi et elle lui avait dit mais
bien sûr on le fera pas et là c'est vrai
qu'on la redécouverte interdiction du
voile dans l'espace public avec le mot
assez fort de guerre civile qu'on peut
comprendre parce que faire la chasse aux
voiles ça va être quand même compliqué
donc c'était c'était plutôt un bon point
la vie pendant l'entre-deux tours
et là Marine Le Pen a dû se rendre
compte que les concessions qu'elle avait
faites à cette vieille française
musulmane qui portait de manière
culturelle en effet son voile voilà ben
c'est concessions fallait pas les faire
ce soir parce que fallait cliver alors
on a que on a accusé pendant très
longtemps Macron de cliver
aussi dans cette émission Christophe
Castanet en direct de contradiction dans
son propos Emmanuel Macron a su
démontrer convaincre je pense et les
spectateurs qui ont assisté à cet
échange on peut apprécier la qualité de
l'échange je veux être très respectueux
en disant cela en particulier pour
Marine Le Pen comme pour Emmanuel Macron
qui a gagné le match
vous savez c'est un débat c'est aux
Français de savoir ce qu'ils ont
retrouvé assumé mon avis ne pas que
c'est pas un match d'abord c'est un
débat il s'agit pas de gagner ou de
perdre il s'agit de convaincre et on a
bien vu que Emmanuel Macron maîtrisait
ses dossiers dominer l'ensemble des
échanges par la connaissance qu'il avait
mais aussi la capacité qu'il a à
projeter le pays et à le projeter pour
les 5 ans qu'ils viennent
de la parole du camp opposé sur la forme
ce soir Emmanuel Macron qui est jugé
arrogant dans son attitude parfois
accoudé sur la table qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça je pense qu'ils auraient
fait exactement les mêmes commentaires
avant le débat je n'ai vu nul arrogance
j'ai vu une cave c'est d'écoute ensuite
si le camp d'adverse comme vous le dites
ne veut pas qu'Emmanuel Macron ait pu
contrarié la candidate du Front national
en même temps faut pas venir dans un
débat il faut faire des conférences de
presse et parler sans prendre les
questions des journalistes parce qu'on
pourrait même penser aussi que la
question des journées sont impertinentes
non faut assumer que dans un débat il la
contradiction et je n'ai vu que de la
contradiction de la part des manuel
Macron à chaque fois qu'elle a pu
affirmer des choses qui étaient
fondamentalement fausses merci beaucoup
la déclaration en direct de Christophe
Castaner on va on va parler des
électeurs de Jean-Luc Mélenchon parce
que ça fait 8 jours ou 9 que
pratiquement tous nos débats tournent
autour de
ce soir est-ce qu'il les ont l'une et
l'autre séduit et si oui comment quand
on commence par Marine Le Pen là on
vient de parler de la question du voile
c'est c'est là que le grand écart est le
plus compliqué pour elle parce que là
c'est vrai que sur les les électeurs de
premier tour de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
ont certainement pas été rassuré par ses
propos sur le voile et je ne vois pas
bien ce qui pendant le débat aurait pu
convaincre les indécis mélenchonistes de
voter Marine Le Pen aucun élément
vraiment saillant n'est ressorti sur les
préoccupations essentielles de cette
électorat qui sont les mêmes que
beaucoup de Français sur le pouvoir
d'achat sur les retraites encore une
fois je me répète mais je trouve qu'elle
a manqué elle aurait pu être vraiment
plus incisive sur ces sujets là et c'est
dommage elle est passée à côté de
quelque chose et par ailleurs ce sont
des électeurs qui pour beaucoup ont
peut-être voté Mélenchon mais viennent
plutôt de la gauche modérée et avait
sans doute besoin éventuellement d'être
rassurés sur sa solidité
avec Alexandre Poussard
oui est-ce que finalement les deux
candidats se sont neutralisés dans ce
débat non mais ce n'est pas comme ça que
moi je pose la question je crois que les
Françaises et les Français comme moi
comme tout le monde ont pu entendre deux
candidats
ils ont pu se faire une idée claire sur
ce qui était les uns et les autres en
termes de qualité humaine de capacité de
leadership en termes de capacité à
décider à assumer la présidence de la
République et de détailler leurs projets
évidemment je vais vous dire que j'ai
trouvé Emmanuel Macron beaucoup plus
convaincant comme Madame le Pennel ça ça
ne vous surprend pas mais la vérité est
que à regarder de près sur l'ensemble
des sujets
quelle était la rigueur des
raisonnements la clarté des propositions
je crois qu'il n'y a pas de doute par
ailleurs l'enjeu ce sont les valeurs
Emmanuel Macron comme c'est
prédécesseurs de Charles de Gaulle
jusqu'à François Mitterrand Nicolas
Sarkozy et François Hollande et bien il
est le garant de ces valeurs de cette
France qu'on aime là où Madame Le Pen
elle est en train de tripatouiller avec
les fondements de la constitution de
notre nation dans quel état d'esprit a
été Emmanuel Macron à la sortie du débat
vous allez vous avez pu lui dire
quelques mots oui nous nous sommes vus
nous avons échangé il était comme
toujours concentré c'est à dire
il avait pu exposer
ses points de vue Madame Le Pen avait pu
le faire il espérait avoir convaincu
avoir explicité un certain nombre de ces
engagements mais il est très concentré
très conscient que
la campagne se continue jusqu'à vendredi
et que le résultat c'est dimanche c'est
pas avant il accompagne n'est pas
terminé merci beaucoup Richard Ferrand
d'avoir répondu communication merci
Alexandre Poussard Michel cotta en
parler à l'instant des électeurs de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qu'il faut aller
chercher dans cette entre-deux tours
puisque Jean-Luc Mélenchon a réalisé
quasiment 22% au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle vous vous avez
vu des signaux qui pourraient les
convaincre je pense notamment à
l'écologie
de la part de Macron oui ça l'écologie
c'est évident c'est des gens qui l'a mis
le paquet là-dessus alors que ça n'était
pas il n'en a pas beaucoup parlé pendant
sa présidence mais ce que je trouve
intéressant sur les électeurs de
Mélenchon c'est que Marine Le Pen aurait
très bien pu exploiter davantage par
exemple le référendum populaire elle
aurait pu c'est un signe
aux électeurs d'Emmanuel Macron mais en
revanche il me semble les que les que
ceux qui votent pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon
n'auront retenu que la première le
premier référendum qui est sur
l'immigration qui est un référendum
effectivement poser problème
constitutionnel et ils ont retenu sur
l'immigration c'est ce qui sépare c'est
ce qui sépare les deux populistes en
disant les choses comme elles sont c'est
ce qui sépare le populisme le gauche du
populisme de droite c'est l'immigration
alors c'est là-dessus qu'elle a mis le
paquet à mon avis mais ça ça se verra
peut-être il y avait je crois environ 25
% des électeurs de Mélenchon qui se
prépare et qui se préparait dans les
sondages à voter Marine Le Pen je ne
suis pas sûr que c'est 25 là c'est 25%
là étaient
séduits par ce discours je suis à mesure
du contraire moi j'ai l'impression c'est
ce que vous disiez Pascal que en effet
là aujourd'hui c'était plutôt un débat à
chacun son discours pour son électorat
propre et j'ai l'impression que les
électeurs de Jean-Luc Mélenchon ils
étaient pas là enfin on les on leur
parlait pas il y a eu beaucoup de
gesticulation pendant l'entre-deux tours
pour ces électeurs on a vu Emmanuel
Macron sur la réforme des retraites sur
l'écologie faire quand même au Pharo à
Marseille voilà des grandes lancées
Marine Le Pen aussi donc modéré on
disait sur le voile là c'était pas du
tout présent
la planification écologique un premier
ministre chargé
mais on peut quand même dire merci
Jean-Luc Mélenchon d'avoir mis en effet
l'écologie au programme de cette
élection de la campagne et puis la
jeunesse la seule mesure à la limite
dont elle a parlé et à mon avis elle en
avait pas parlé avant c'était les trains
gratuit elle a parlé de du train gratuit
en heure creuse
pour les jeunes mais je trouve qu'en
tout cas non mais ce référendum sur les
éoliennes
effectivement elle dit aux Français en
tout cas je trouve que c'est intéressant
qu'on est quand même plus dans ce débat
qui a duré deux heures 50 je sais pas si
c'est combien de temps ça a duré
peut-être 20 minutes si on compte
l'écologie plus la jeunesse mais c'est
quand même la relativement absent de la
campagne pour une fois on en a parlé pas
beaucoup pas des choses phénoménales et
les révolutionnaires mais c'était déjà
pas mal vous savez ce que c'est donc on
a entendu deux soutien d'Emmanuel Macron
il nous faut un
de Marine Le Pen c'est Jordan Bardella
le président du Rassemblement national
elle a fait le choix peut-être par
rapport à 2017 moins d'attaquer Emmanuel
Macron que de proposer d'expliquer aux
Français ce qu'elle comptait mettre en
oeuvre à partir de lundi pour améliorer
leur pouvoir d'achat pour améliorer leur
sécurité pour maîtriser l'immigration de
notre pays qui est devenu hors de
contrôle les Français connaissent bien
maintenant le bilan d'Emmanuel Macron
ils savent qu'ils ont de plus en plus de
mal à boucler les fins de mois avec une
grande partie ces difficultés sont
imputables à Emmanuel Macron ils savent
que le laxisme judiciaire qui encercle
aujourd'hui
l'ensemble des Français qui ne sont plus
en sécurité lorsqu'ils sont dans les
Russes c'est le bilan d'Emmanuel Macron
ils savent que le manque de respect
d'Emmanuel Macron à l'égard des Français
tout au long de son quinquennat la
brutalité qu'il a exprimé notamment à
l'égard de ce grand mouvement populaire
qui ont été les gilets jaunes c'est le
bilan d'Emmanuel Macron donc cette
affrontement démocratique cette
confrontation d'idées et pas de temps le
lieu pour critiquer l'adversaire que
pour expliquer ce qu'on propose aux
Français et je pense que c'est ce qui a
assez bien fait ce soir Marine Le Pen on
sera soulagé quand la campagne sera
terminée il y a encore deux jours de
campagne deux jours intense de campagne
que Marine Le Pen passera sur le terrain
elle sera deux mains dans le
Pas-de-Calais où elle donnera son
dernier grand meeting à Arras donc on va
continuer à faire campagne on va
continuer à convaincre les Français je
pense que les Français choisissent
toujours en dernière instance celui qui
en a plus envie et je pense que ce soit
celle qui a en tout cas l'envie je pense
que c'est Marine Le Pen qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé de la séquence sur le
Pérusse quand Emmanuel Macron lui a dit
quand vous parlez à la Russie vous
parlez à votre banquier
dédain l'arrogance une forme de trans
qui caractérise assez bien le mandat
d'Emmanuel Macron je pense que ce type
de ce type d'attaque n'est pas de son
niveau c'est assez paradoxal d'empêcher
des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle de trouver des banques en
France et ensuite de leur reprocher
d'aller trouver des banques à l'étranger
la vérité c'est que ça a souligné l'une
des grandes promesses démocratiques
d'Emmanuel Macron qui était la banque de
la démocratie qui avait promis en 2007
comme la proportionnelle d'ailleurs
qu'il n'a pas tenu donc est-ce qu'on
continue cinq années de plus avec le
saccage social avec la saignée fiscale
avec l'explosion de la délinquance et la
criminalité où est-ce qu'on décide de
rétablir l'état de redonner du pouvoir
d'achat aux Français et c'est ce choix
là qui va se poser aux Français qui va
engager non pas le pays pour les cinq
prochaines années mais peut-être pour
les 50 prochaines c'est toujours
difficile d'avoir ça a été un débat de
bonne tenue où on a pu aborder un grand
nombre de sujets évidemment sans
toujours avec un peu de frustration
parce que on aurait aimé développer
l'intégralité de son projet mais c'est
pas possible en 2h30 voilà il faut
l'admettre en fait en 1h15 ça n'est pas
possible mais voilà moi j'ai trouvé que
le débat c'était déroulé rapidement je
sais pas si les les gens qui ont regardé
ont eu le même sentiment je le souhaite
je l'espère plus rapide plus structuré
oui plus
plus calme en effet oui est-ce que vous
estimez avoir gagné cette fois face à
Emmanuel Macron
[Musique]
je parle de me lancer là-dedans ça
m'intéresse assez peu mais le débat
s'est déroulé
encore une fois sereinement
correctement et c'est ce qui est le plus
important parce que c'est ce que je
crois attendez français
on va soulager vous savez quand vous
ferez un débat à la présidentielle pour
ceux qu'on en parlera évidemment on
était on est heureux quand on a pu
exposer
quasiment l'intégralité de son projet
évidemment
parler plus des aidants des de
l'outre-mer de des TPE bien sûr mais
voilà c'est la règle du jeu il faudrait
accepter qu'est-ce que vous avez pas
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de la taxe
sur le prêt russe Madame Le Pen bon je
m'y attendais très objectivement je
pense que ça démontre aussi que il y a
assez peu de d'attaques qui portent sur
le fond en fait du projet moi j'ai
entendu depuis 10 jours beaucoup de
dénaturation de mon projet enfin j'ai
entendu parler de choses je ne
reconnaissais pas ce que je propose aux
Français
beaucoup d'outrans parfois même des
insultes après tout je peux vous dire ce
soir je suis contente qu'Emmanuel Macron
n'est pas suivi la technique de campagne
de ses équipes qui
ne se grandissent pas en faisant ce
genre de choses parce que une
présidentielle ces projets contre projet
c'est pas projet qu'on trouve trans
projet contre-insulte projet contre
agressivité projet contre la totalité
c'est pas ça un second tour et c'est
parce qu'attendais français il a quand
même dit que vous amèneriez le pays à la
guerre civile allez on reprend on
reprend la main et puis on équilibrera
dans nos prochaines émissions
après que c'est normal on est
transparent avec nos téléspectateurs il
reste plusieurs jours dans cette
campagne vous inquiétez pas en
respectera les règles aller à un dernier
mot Michel cotation
on cherche toujours un gagnant et c'est
normal tout le monde se pose la question
on a on a les uns les autres plutôt le
sentiment qu'il y en a pas eu ça veut
dire que les tendances de ces derniers
jours que l'on voyait poindre sondage
après sondage devrait se maintenir
d'après vous c'est-à-dire un écart assez
important pour Emmanuel Macron je trouve
quand même on peut Marine Le Pen à
essuyer la tâche de sa première de son
premier échec ça je pense qu'on veut le
dire maintenant sur beaucoup de points
quand même moi personnellement j'ai
trouvé le président plus plus au fait
des choses et peut-être plus
convaincantes plus peut-être quoi qu'on
en dise quoi qu'on puisse en dire Marine
Le Pen a du caractère quoi c'est là on
l'a vu maintenant je pense que pour être
président il faut du caractère mais il
faut peut-être pas uniquement ça il nous
reste deux jours de campagne puisque
termine vendredi soir à minuit parce
qu'elle Perrineau un conseil pour chacun
des deux candidats dès qu'on reste sur
ce ton extrêmement civil moi j'ai trouvé
et ça m'a rassuré parce qu'on pouvait
s'attendre à ce que ça tourne un peu au
pugilat c'est vrai que pendant 8 jours
on se disait tiens on retrouve vraiment
la grosse artillerie les grosses
ficelles et là on a eu une certaine
civilité et même un certain humour un
moment en effet quand Marine Le Pen dit
nous avons vieilli
ensemble bon je trouve que ça fait du
bien parce que ça c'est un débat
démocratie
quelque chose d'un peu grave c'est qu'on
a complètement normalisé c'est vrai
qu'elle a réparé ses erreurs mais alors
voilà le procès en incapacité le procès
en extrême était pas tellement présent
c'est quand même d'extrême droite et on
l'a pas beaucoup vu ce soir à tous
d'avoir participé à à ce débat merci
Brigitte on se retrouve dimanche on se
retrouve dimanche dès 19h30 pour le
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
ce sera sur les chaînes parlementaires
LCP et Public Sénat et merci à toutes
les équipes de Public Sénat qui étaient
sur le pont ce soir jusqu'à minuit 31
merci
[Musique]